anthologie des écrits de l'egypte
ancienne c'est le nom de cet imposant
ouvrage qui est signée d'un mini montant
vous résidez à montigny le bretonneux
claude carrier bonsoir suivent linois
vous allez nous parler de ce livre c'est
votre actualité au cours des prochaines
minutes
j'aimerais déjà savoir depuis quand êtes
vous séduit par l'egypte l'egypte
ancienne comme beaucoup de français je
vais beaucoup du ça m'a beaucoup
intéressé et puis en 1977 avec deux amis
on est parti en voiture de paris et on a
été en egypte en voiture et c'était en
plein mois d'août il n'y avait pas un
touriste
donc on a pu montrer absolument partout
mais son charme
en plus tout à fait tout à fait et donc
ensuite quand j'ai été un 10 ans de ma
mise en inactivité
je me suis dit que j'allais m'intéresser
à un peu plus sérieusement visite et
j'ai commencé à étudier le gepci
hiéroglyphique donc c'est une seconde
vie en face à la monnaie nous est
ingénieur à la retraite depuis genève
nous sommes sales et réalisé un
micro-trottoir on va parler de votre
livre ensuite de cet ouvrage un joli
disait imposant parce que c'est un vrai
recueil et c'est assez intéressant il ya
des comptes aussi vous allez nous dire
on trouve aussi des comptes c'est un peu
comme des comme des fables c'est toute
une civilisation qui se livre qui se
découvre à travers l' ouvrage que vous
avez écrit ce micro-trottoir cette
question que nous vous avons posé
l'egypte ancienne vous fassiez intel et
pourquoi
oui je suis attiré par l'égypte ancienne
parce que ça fait partie de l'histoire
c'est quand même une histoire millénaire
et puis
très très riche depuis comment dire ça
l'histoire des phares ans et quand même
passionnant absolument pas
oui mais j'ai jamais eu le temps
vraiment de d'approfondir le sujet
peut-être quand j'aurais le temps sans
plus pour que sommes dans le trou moins
que par le à la grèce je peux faire la
grèce c'est généralement l'une des
premières choses dans l'enfance qu'on
lequel on est attiré une ancienneté de
la civilisation le fait que cette
civilisation soit apparue comme
apparemment presque de nulle part en
faisant des choses comment colossal et
en plus le côté immuable de leur
religion sur plusieurs millénaires
donc voilà langil égyptiens qui s'est
lui majoritairement les saint quentinois
les yvelinois comme l'ensemble des
français d'ailleurs on est forcément
sous le charme de cette civilisation il
ya beaucoup de fantasmes aussi autour de
de l'egypte ancienne toujours mais avec
ce texte avec ses ouvrages que vous avez
regroupés à l'intérieur de d'un unique
roken vous poser les bases de la
civilisation on y découvre tour une
société très hiérarchisée par exemple
les groupes des textes funéraire on y
découvre des comptes aussi un jeu évoqué
tout à l'heure d'où viennent les
différences écrit que vous avez
synthétiser et regrouper ses j'ai essayé
de proposer au plus grand nombre
un éventail qui recouvre à peu près
toutes les grandes familles de textes
que l'on peut retrouver dans les écrits
de l'egypte ancienne
alors bien sûr les textes religieux qui
sont très importants ensuite les comptes
les sagesses qui sont des écrits un peu
philosophique très très intéressant
quand on est quand on les analyse
ensuite les lettres parce que les
égyptiens écrivait beaucoup donc
heureusement ça nous laisse des traces
de leur vie un peu quotidienne ensuite
j'ai pris des textes juridiques bien sûr
désigne puisque il avait tout un
éventail de divinités et puis j'ai
terminé
par des textes qu'on peut qualifier
d'historique dans la plupart étaient
gravés sur des murs ou des monuments et
on y apprend encore on y apprend le
fonctionnement les rouages de cette
société il y en a on voit effectivement
apparaître les relations entre kiel et
les différentes strates delà de la
civilisation égyptienne à la société
égyptienne et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que quand on parle de l'egypte ont
tout de suite on pense alors monument
mais derrière il ya toute une toute une
somme décrit imposant et parce que
finalement l'egypte est quand même la
civilisation qui a duré le plus
longtemps sur notre terre plus de 3000
ans et c'est quand même assez
exceptionnel
et parmi ces différents écrits c'est
vrai que ça m'a plutôt interpellé il ya
ses comptes mais évoque encore une fois
le compte du crocodile de cirque oncle
du naufrage et aussi à qui s'adressent
ces comptes il est l ua qui opposa les
offres soir c'était inouï avec des
conteurs je pense comme encore dans
beaucoup de sociétés africaines
actuellement se réunissaient c'est ça
est il donc quelqu'un racontait ses
histoires
voilà ensuite elles se sont transmises
il reste quoi ensuite parce que là vous
avez regroupés à travers un ouvrage vous
l'avais dit c'était écrit parfois sur
des sur des parois sur des murs mais
est-ce que ça s'est transmis ensuite
qu'est ce qu'il reste aujourd'hui de la
civilisation de cette egypte ancienne
dans l'égypte aujourd'hui l'existence
d'un sentiment aussi même une portion
risque qui reste sortirait ce sila
là la société coptes puisque ce sont les
seuls descendants directs de l'egypte
pharaonique et c'est d'ailleurs par le
copte que champollion a réussi à
découvrir un déchiffrer les hiéroglyphes
parce que c'est vrai que l'egypte terre
ancienne a été une civilisation sans
précédent mais aujourd'hui l'egypte
n'est plus dans la même dynamique dont
l'egypte où vous côté le regard vous
avez sur cette évolution de la société
égyptienne
quelle instance et s'est passé il ya
beaucoup de points d'interrogations
ça peut paraître surprenant de voir
qu'une telle civilisation revient des
situations beaucoup plus compliqué
conflictuelle parce que finalement ils
ont été envahies par les par les arabes
qui sont venus d'arabie saoudite et donc
ça ça à transformer tout l'egypte et
puis tout le maghreb derrière le livre
que vous publiez
aujourd'hui s'adresse à qui a des
historiens des universités non je pense
et non grand public parce que les les
spécialistes connaissent ces textes et
donc c'est pour mettre à sa disposition
du public du plus grand nombre ses
écrits qui me paraissent intéressants et
qu'est ce qui vous a pas trop par le
plus intéressant qu'est ce qui vous a
interpellé le plus à travers les
différents textes square cause les
comptes les textes les décrets c'est des
textes religieux c'est sûr parce que il
ya un continuum de textes depuis la
l'époque des pyramides jusqu'à le nouvel
empire et la période
finale où ces textes religieux perdurer
sont utilisés encore d'un dans les tons
et notamment le livre des morts que tous
les les personnes
disons que la haute société g
pharaonique emmené avec elle pour passer
dans l'au delà et essayer d'avoir une
vie calquée sur la vie terrestre
si vous voulez découvrir l'ensemble de
ces textes je vous recommande donc ce
livre de claude carrier anthologie des
écrits de l'egypte ancienne vous serez à
tous sur le fonctionnement de cette
société il ya plusieurs façons d'y
entrer dans cet ouvrage que vous avez
publié aux éditions thélès votre
prochaine étude au génome elle est vite
j'ai commencé j'ai commencé une série
sur les différents livres des morts et
je continue merci quand ariel est revenu
sur ce plateau je remercie de ce livre
anthologie des écrits de l'egypte
ancienne
éditions thélès merci